لم تندثر اثار المعركه في بلده متريسكا
هذه بدايه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه كما
لم يختفي حجم التاثير الذي شكلته الاسلحه
المستخدمه بها من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
التي تصدت لاليات القوات الروسيه وكبدتها
خسائر كبيره في هذا المكان على اطراف
العاصمه كييف وقعت ما سميت بمجزره
الدبابات حيث اعترضت القوات الاوكرانيه
ارتالا من الاليات الروسيه باستخدام سلاح
جافلان المضاد للدروع اول الاسلحه الغربيه
التي وصلت اوكرانيا
وبعد عام على الحرب يكشف العقيد الكسندر
قائد الكتيبه 72 التي تولت معارك كييف
للجزيره عن اهم اسرار تلك المعارك
كل ما ترونه من اليات مدمره استهدفناها
باسلحه زودنا بها شركائنا الغربي لا سيما
سلاحي جافلين وان لاو وتدربنا عليهما قبل
الحرب
الاسلحه الغربيه المضاده للدروع على
اختلاف انواعها اضافه الى مسيرات
البيرقدار التركيه مكنت الاوكرانيين من
استعاده بلداتهم ودفع القوات الروسيه الى
ما بعد الحدود الشماليه ما شكل نقطه فارقه
في الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا كما يقول لنا
ايغور احد ابرز عربي اتفاقات السلاح مع
الغرب
لم نتسلم الكثير من الاسلحه في الايام
الاولى سوى مضادات الدروع الا ان اثباتنا
القدره على المقاومه وحمايه عاصمتنا شجع
الحلفاء على منحنا اسلحه ثقيله على مراحل
ونتوقع منهم تزويدنا بكل ما نحتاجه من
كافه انواع الاسلحه
باتجاه الجبهات المشتعله شرقا وجنوبا
ارسلت الاسلحه النوعيه لاوكرانيا حيث خصت
جبهات الشرق كباخمت وخاركيف بالمدافع
الامريكيه عاليه الدقه كالها ومثيلاته
الاوروبيه فيما وجهت نحو الجنوب قذفات
الصواريخ الحديثه والمضادات الجويه
بعد كان الانسحاب الكبير من مقاطعه
الشرقيه ومدينه خرزون الجنوبيه بعدما تلقت
القوات الاوكرانيه هناك الدعم الصاروخيه
والمدفعيه اللازم المصحوبه بطائرات
الاستطلاع والى الجنوب نتجه للتعرف على
تاثيرها
في طريقنا نرصد وصول مزيد من الدفاعات
الجويه كهذا السلاح الالماني الفعال ضد
الطائرات المسيره وعلى الطريق ذاته عبرت
قاذفات هايس الامريكيه تظهر هذه اللقطات
التي منحنا اياها الجيش الاوكراني لحظه
توجهها نحو الجنوب
اطلاقها رشقات صاروخيه وصل مداها الى 80
كيلومترا نحو مواقع القوات الروسيه في
خرسون وتدميرها
الى الانسحاب خلفه
وبعدما وصلت نيرانهم الى هنا باتوا
يطالبون بصواريخ يفوق مداها 150 كيلومترا
تمكنها من اصابه شبه جزيره القرم وما فيها
من مواقع ومستودعات استراتيجيه بالاضافه
الى طلب طائرات حربيه على وقع انتظار وصول
الدبابات الغربيه الحديثه
نحو الضفه الاخرى حيث تتمركز القوات
الروسيه جنوبيه خرسون وما بعدها يريد
الاوكرانيون ان تصل صواريخهم والياتهم
التي ينتظرونها من حلفائهم
وللانتصار في هذه الحرب يبدو ان الحاجه
ليست لطول مدى الصواريخ فحسب
حسن مسعود الجزيره
خرسون